the soap industry yeah it's overly
promoted is that well all hygiene
products they often started with this
idea that where they they created this
idea that you were unclean unless you
used it so the classic example is
Listerine promoted the idea that
halitosis was a specific condition that
you could have without knowing about it
they invented this medical sounding term
halitosis they coined the term before
that no one thought I have bad breath
until they through relentless ads made
us think that way so if industry did the
same thing they promoted the idea that
you should bathe every day and then if
you don't you're like covered with a
film that you need to get off you know
and it's so effective I mean I today you
know bathes with soap every day despite
knowing this is despite doing the
research just by talking to a
dermatologist on our show saying you
don't need to use soap every day you
know you'll dry out your skin maybe if
you do I still do it because it's been
instilled in me from childhood but isn't
it also will start to smell bad I mean
after a day or two I mean yeah but
there's there's gradations yes of course
you know you should bathe when you're
when you're you know dirty or whatever
but um you know if you had that friend
in college who like went a day or two
like and they were like I don't know
what you're talking about I'm fine I
like my roommate was like that my
roommate was right the whole time you
know what you have a you have a thing
about your welcome Ben yeah you have a
thing about TOMS shoes
oh yeah TOMS shoes so Tom's shoe started
to buy one give one campaign right and
that is it's not on the face of it bad
but these companies that do buy one give
one often really inflate the degree to
which this is a charitable act you know
if you talk to people in the countries
where they're donating these shoes those
they'll tell you we don't really need
shoes that bad like that's not our issue
that's based on us in America we're like
we have some image in our head of like
oh yeah there's like villagers walking
out without shoes and they're probably
walking around going but I've only I had
shoes everything it happened would be
better you know right they're worried
about malaria stuff like that you know
and but actually if you think about the
impact on people who make shoes in those
countries they lose business because
we're air dropping all of these by the
way very cheap shoes that Tom Shoesmith
they're not really lasting you know in
the bush you know what I mean but I am
I'm curious I'm curious you said that
the this these countries that they don't
need the shoes do you think it's that
it's it's an act to me it seems almost
like these companies want to make you
feel less guilty about shopping yeah if
you buy the product you'll probably if
they give you some sort of grander
gesture that you're making when you buy
yes you know buy this Lamborghini and
we'll send some onions to this country
maybe you feel better about buying the
Lamborghini exactly exactly I mean
that's sort of I think yeah are you
underpinning and when you talk to people
who work in international development
they say the problem with these
companies is that there's so much focus
all of the focus of the pitch is on how
it's gonna make you feel as a consumer
it's all focused on the American buying
the shoe oh now when you buy the shoe
you're gonna know you're gonna make a
good deed they're not why are they
giving away shoes because they're a shoe
company trying to sell shoes you're not
going to you know Uganda say what do you
guys really need otherwise they wouldn't
be giving them shoes it's it's in order
to make the sale
you